my mom always said that um
it's always best to give
bitter news with honey and so if you
know anything about
bob and the science behind his music
every
song has a one drop rhythm and the one
drop rhythm is a simulation of our
heartbeat
so
do that's photographer ruddy roy
talking about reggae icon bob marley so
he wants
to find your vibration and it's the
vibration that everybody lives with
is the vibration of a heartbeat and he
uses that
to push the needle in and that needle is
the sound of your heartbeat and he gets
you to the music
and once you're there he cannot give you
the medicine and those are the words i
mean he never left that methodology
so why is a documentary photographer
musing about reggae music
[Music]
i'm peter gwynne editor-at-large at
national geographic magazine
and you're listening to overheard at
national geographic
a show where we eavesdrop on the wild
conversations we have here at netgeo
and follow them to the edges of our big
weird beautiful world
this week we sit down with photographer
rudy roy as he talks about growing up in
jamaica
and how the songs of reggae musician bob
marley prepared him for a journalism
career
and ultimately led him to the front
lines of the coveted 19 pandemic
in the civil rights protests
[Music]
can you take me back to jamaica in your
childhood like what what's your earliest
memory of jamaica
you know i in the 70s in jamaica were
tumultuous
it was it our country went through
this idea of
michael manley versus
edward thiaga and it was really
the people's national party versus the
jamaica labor party
and i remember as a kid going to school
watching people run up chase each other
with broomsticks with
with two by fours um you'd hear on the
news
people shooting at each other different
parties shooting at each other
and out of all of that tyranny
came music
leroy smart would sing ballistic a fear
and it's these are the songs i grew up
on um
i need a roof over my head yeah the
mighty diamonds by mighty diamonds yeah
and then rita mali brought to the fro
the idea of the the woman's voice and
she sang harambe again peace
this idea of oneness
and i think in jamaica
it was either the church songs
or the thunk the songs from these
entertainers
that really lifted us out of that
tumultuous time
so tell me about your uh tell me about
your parents
what are they like both were from the
country like rural
so it would be compatible to see there
from down south
they both both their parents were
farmers but my mom
grew up on a farm yeah we went to the
farm
it was one of the sweetest part of the
vacation because we didn't though we
didn't work the land because the
i mean they thought that our hand our
hands were too soft
but we were allowed to go sit in the
cane feet like they could never find me
yeah but my mom said all she would do is
to look over
in the cane field and wherever she saw
the bush doing this
she knew it was me because i was in
there doing this
and tearing the cane with my teeth yeah
and it would shake the bush
so she would know exactly where to find
me um
my mom my mom got her
her discipline from being a girl who
grew up on a farm
she's one of the most hardworking people
i know
beautiful witty wise
she was one of the first women in
jamaica to run 10 seconds
in 1968. are you sure are you sure
but she couldn't get to go to the world
cup because she got pregnant
oh my gosh wait a minute she ran 10
seconds
in the hundred meters in 100 yard dash
100
yes that is phenomenal wow
well jamaica's known for sprinters i
mean that that's i guess that's a long
tradition i didn't realize that
it's in the food man it's it's it's how
we train it's
so my father was
my father was quiet he was he was the
first person
that i thought about when i
when i was when i started studying
philosophy he was the first person i
thought about
and he always had stories every
lesson that he had to teach it was done
through a story and i think more than
anything else
that's where i got that from but my love
for art i know definitely came from my
mom
she gave me books very early she gave me
poetry very early
um she gave me music around age nine or
ten
wow at what point ready did you start to
pick
the idea that you know you wanted to get
into photography when did you sort of
pick up a camera
i got an assignment to photograph people
who are living on the defunct train line
in montego bay
so the train the train that used to run
from kingston to montego bay had stopped
running
and it had stopped running for such a
long time that people were now
living on the train line they they took
over the train houses
they were living close to the train
because it was good property
and the newspaper said why don't you go
up there and do a story on a family
that's now living so
because if the train comes back these
families would have to move
um so i went and i did it and i walked
121 miles
from montego bay to kingston finished
the project wow
wow and used those images
to get a job at the associated press
in new york oh my goodness and that was
the that's the beginning of
that this journey so walking from your
hometown to the capitol
in jamaica taking pictures all the way
is what led you to your professional
career really in a way
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so ready tell me about your first
national geographic assignment i mean
i'm
yeah you know we're we're skipping big
chunks here but tell me about the first
you know call you got from geographic
and what what was that
first the first assignment i got was to
photograph
the the people
or the individuals who were donating
their artifacts to the smithsonian
african-american museum in washington dc
um for me it was a huge deal because
i was photographing people who have
lived
with the with nat turner's bible
they have lived with their ancestors
free paper yeah
they had lived with the
the clothes that and the belongings of
james baldwin um
and for me finally
they were going to be put in a space
where
they could be shared in the world
i often i was i was often quoted as
saying that i would never go to anybody
else's museum until
i had one and and so
finally i get to like embrace
a history that i thought that was
lacking it was it was it was it was a
it was beautiful to me it was beautiful
to travel around the country
photographing
nat turner's great great great great
grandson and seen a history
that is not in our history books it's
not told anywhere
um photographing a sign that says
blackett signposts
and knowing that this signpost
was was erected to to
to instill fear in any
other people of african descent
who were who was working in virginia for
free
from having another insurrection and
that's why that sign was there
it said blackhead signpost still
in virginia wow and so the
every story that i've done for for
geographic everyone
i followed that up with the race issue
which made me made me sit
at morehouse university and and look at
the next generation
of of of our black leaders
um and see
the pros and cons of of what it means to
to grow up in a country that does not
feed you its history
i've learned i've learned more from
these than i think i've been able to
like
put into these pictures interesting
interesting um these are
actually the histories of the history
that i've
brought back to my to my sons
to the to the to the effect that when my
son was given this
this assignment to to write on a civil
rights leader
he said to his teacher that he'd prefer
to write about his father
because that's where he gets his history
from wow
so these stories
have been more than just stories for me
yeah
they have been paging pages in a history
that has not been written yet because
it's not a part of our curriculum
and it's not in our history books yeah
so you mentioned you have two sons
it's interesting i think your son you
have a son who's 12 just turned 12 i
guess this summer right right
i have two daughters a 12 year old and a
14 year old and so
i kind of know in terms of age what
that's like but i can only imagine
well i know you know like talking to my
children
about this moment that we're all living
through but as the father of
black children how do you how are you
talking to them about all of this and
how are you talking about what you do
with your work
well it's it's it's beautiful to see
especially this summer my son
the 15 year old blossom into the kind of
photographer
that it sounds narcissistic for me to
say but it feels like me
which means that he can only
push off from a good space
i watched him photograph some kids at
at the park for his uh his photography
assignment
and i made sure that i was like away
and i could hear him talk and ask
questions and move the person
emotionally to get the images that he
wanted wow
and i was just like i felt good because
i'm always like
and this might sound morbid i always
think about leaving
like dying like i always think if i left
him no
yeah would he be okay right and so
and so hearing him move into this place
that i'm like
yes like yes like if i was
unfortunately to leave right now right
i kind of know his how his vision would
mature yeah right bar any
corruption any anything because i've
been very good about
not allowing capitalism to corrupt
the way i choose images or
shoot display or tell stories
um but we sit down and we talk about
weekly events i mean we don't do it
every day
but we did george floyd because i was
old
um in houston um
and what did what did you say to them
and and how did they respond
actually i started off by saying to them
that when i was
i was allowed to go into the church and
photograph george floyd i did not
photograph him
for 12 minutes like people were behind
me going dude
let's go yeah holding up the line but
for me it was important
to tell george's body
thanks thanks for his life thanks for
the the opportunities that we're all
gonna get
because of his death thanks for
thanks for what is going to shift the
narrative that's going to
be moved because of his death and it was
important to do that
and i wanted them to understand that
moment
that you're not going gonna get um
angela davis on the front of the was it
vanity fair just because
a briana taylor does not go on the front
of a magazine
just because you know
we're getting all of this this influx of
of of interest and attention
is coming from us all these names all
these hashtags
and so it was important for me to let
him understand what that
death means for us that is not just
he's dead and gone and he here's another
dead
person that's not going to be a hashtag
that his death is going to allow us
new life new a new voice
a new push and that our job
is to be to be a part of this struggle
and a part of this fight in a very
positive way
um they can't go anywhere they
understand what that is
i do not allow them to ride around the
block
in cleveland they cannot go take their
bikes and go outside without
me or their mom watching them
that's the reality
you know you've recently been named as a
new as one of the national geographic
storytellers
and your project is titled when living
is a protest
yes can you explain kind of what your
what you're thinking
what's your plan for that project it's
it's to go somewhere deeper than
everyday life i mean i could easily say
over the past 400 years our entire
living has been one out of protest
um i'd give you an image i'll give you
something to imagine just imagine
for an instance watching your entire
watching as a family your father being
raped in front of you and you cannot
move
imagine your mom being raped you cannot
move
if you move you're going to be killed
imagine your uncle your brother
your father maybe a neighbor being hung
being whipped cannot move
because if you move you're going to be
killed no imagine you
holding that and imagine seeing this
every day of your life for as long as
you're alive
and then you're free but
that pain is passed on in your dna on a
very cellular level
and imagine that it hasn't stopped
imagine that they still
kill imagine that through redlining and
jim crow they're still
lynching there's still places that you
can't
live own property you can
go to a water fountain you can
ride in the front of the bus imagine
that there there's variations but there
is still
subjugation and imagine you still pass
that on
imagine the civil rights movement
come and your leaders get killed
and imagine then still you pass that on
and we come to 2020
and then imagine the
trauma that folks have had to live with
for 400 years
and so for me those
images of these images are about
a quote that albert camus said
uh and i know i'm gonna butcher that
quote he said when a people have
suffered they develop a taste for the
misfortune
i think that's it when a people have
suffered they
develop a taste for the misfortune
and it is that quote that drives the
world
well ready i'd love to end on a hopeful
note
um and maybe that's the future and
specifically you know i
i in your instagram post with your sons
it seems like there's a lot of hope
there i mean you've already talked a
little bit about that but
i remember one of the posts you talked
about yoshi
is he the younger or the older son he's
the younger the younger i think you said
yoshi
carries my heart and your older son
carries your spear
it's the other way around oh it's the
other way i'm sorry
okay yo she carries the spear despair
moses my heart
if you were gonna paint the tableau of
the future you would hope
to see yoshi and moses
have the country they would live in the
place we would be as a society can you
can you sort of
you know paint that picture what that
would look like for me
for me there's this a very
it's a very nuanced and complex
scenario to even
in my unqualified
knowledge try to even broach but i'll
see this
i think the lack of respect that african
americans get
is because we're not unified
and we don't have the economic
power and resources that would
allow other people outside of our group
to look at us and go and it comes from
the fact that nobody knows
our achievements because our
achievements are integrated into
the larger narrative
that said hip-hop came out of this idea
that
this was our voice our culture and we
sold it all to the back of
cars i think that was the
one intersection where the rest of the
world
were looked at african-americans i was
like yo we need to get a piece of that
i think we can go back to that and i
think
i think it we have to live in a world
where
i i will buy i will go out and support
blackness until we can sit at the table
and garner respect until
until my choice to go to g-star and buy
a pair of jeans
is my choice and not the only choice i
have
and until we we get to that space
will always be here like will always be
somebody told me today that we're
finally going to get to a space where
where things are legislated and i think
that's the wrong approach
because it's now based on somebody else
giving us something
we just need to get into our own
communities and start
farming building our masonry electrical
work
just start doing for ourselves
supporting and then
find that we have something to bring to
the table that we can know
do this we can exchange
i think i think if i and which is why i
keep telling
telling my boys that they have to to to
to be about loving
loving who they are loving their culture
not today i mean i i hope when when when
i when people hear me say this it's not
saying that
i don't love white culture or i don't
love
brown culture just for political the
political sense because i hate that word
brown
or my sons have the distinction of
having a mom who is half chinese
um and so they they do adopt
parts of the chinese culture and their
father
is jamaican so they do adopt a lot of
the jamaican culture and they are
americans and so they live in an
american culture
and way before
people were talking about girls and the
fact that you
can't say you hit like a girl i was
having a conversation with them at them
at five and
and two or six
and three like they couldn't i was i
said
girls can beat you they run faster than
you
your grandmother can outrun you yes
still so so so i've i've
always tried to give them this very
holistic way
of of of being in the world yeah
but as they're doing that they have to
start loving
theirs and appreciating theirs
and not believe that outside of theirs
is better than theirs yeah
right right and we have to get to that
space we have to get to the space where
we
we truly love our culture
enough to be able to to live in it
before we give it up i i'll say this on
the record
integration really
hurt the black community
hurt it and and it's it's in our history
books
that the first we call that word the the
people who
were against it um were teachers
because they said as soon as these black
kids were able to go to white schools
their history would no longer be taught
and so these
kids are brought up without their
history
so they don't know how they what their
achievements were
the one thing about jamaica that i can
tell you we went to school because we
loved hearing about nani
samsha marcus gavi paul bogle
um nanny of the maroons
george washington george william garden
we love um you see all the american and
the
the jamaican just got mixed up um
but we loved hearing about our history
that is the thing the one thing that's
lacking
i think in our curriculum that these
kids are
are brought up to hear about the history
that they have no connection to
yeah yeah well listen
uh i really appreciate you taking the
time and this has been a fascinating
conversation and
moving and i feel like you've given me a
gift now that i
i have to i have the responsibility to
make sure that it
is you know i do justice to it so i want
to thank you and
i really look forward to meeting you in
person someday hopefully we'll be back
in
some day and have another photo seminar
or you'll be at the office and
and showing a photo show or something
and we get to meet in person
that would be wonderful brother yeah
yeah ready well thanks again
thank you so much
[Music]
to see some of roddy roy's national
geographic assignments
including his coverage of the opening of
the national museum of african american
history
and culture his portraits from
historically black colleges and
universities
as well as his most recent photographs
depicting the impact of covet 19 on
people of color
and the black lives matter protests
check out the links in our show notes
or right there in your podcast app you
can also find us photographs on our
instagram account
at nat geo
[Music]
overheard at national geographic is
produced by brian gutierrez
jacob pinter and laura sim our senior
editor is eli
chen executive producer of audio is
davar
ardellan who also produced this episode
our fact checker is michelle harris
hansdale sue composed our theme music
and engineers our episodes this podcast
is a production of national geographic
partners
whitney johnson is the director of
visuals and immersive experiences
susan goldberg is national geographic's
editorial director
and i'm your host peter gwyn thanks for
listening
and see you all next time
[Music]
you